well good morning or good afternoon
uh um glad to be here with you and
thanks for the kind introduction maggie
um i uh uh my name is stuart neal i'm a
professor
uh an assistant professor of pathology
and laboratory medicine at emory
university
um been in practice now for about five
years
and i'm a trained uh neuropathologist
that's my area of specialization
and oh some time ago now we
uh at emory started uh running
chromosomal microarrays on
on on most of the brain tumors that we
diagnose
at our institution um and uh so i am
here this morning to give you
some updates on the use of broad
spectrum copy number data
in the clinical workup of cns neoplate
neoplasia so
let's get started so this is a
uh disclosure provided uh by a
thermofisher scientific um
and uh it just basically uh
is a standard slide and we will move
along
speaking of standard slides these are my
disclosures and i don't
have any conflicts of interest to uh to
note
uh i've not been paid for this uh uh for
this presentation and and uh
um that's all to say about that
so what are we gonna be doing today
we're going to be um
uh reviewing the use of copy number data
in the modern assessment of cns
neoplasia that's a big topic
uh we're just going to be trying to hit
some of the highlights
and uh in particular we're going to be
summarizing the importance of
newer diagnostic paradigms including
those derived from the c
impact now project in the workup of
gliomas
so first things first let's just review
where we are with genomic data and cns
diaplasia
basically testing for genomic findings
is necessary for the diagnosis of
several cns neoplasms and the number
of neoplasms for which it is critical is
growing
really by the month um
that's uh these are developments driven
by gains in knowledge
research and then the resultant
updated classifications and uh
those updated classifications um
really made a big step forward back in
2016 when the
who for cns neoplasms was updated
um and in that update it codified
certain genomic abnormalities as
definitional for particular diagnoses so
basically in order to make certain
diagnoses
in neuropathology you have to
demonstrate
certain genomic abnormalities and i know
many folks are are
are familiar with this at this point but
i just provide some examples
of some of the particular abnormalities
listed below
and you'll note that some of these are
mutations some of these are copy number
abnormalities and some of these
are uh fusion events
so in practice um basically
it this this change has has really
rocked the field of neuropathology if
you uh
practiced it all before the current
genomic era
this could be something of a shock for
you basically it really requires that we
do genomic testing on a very large
number of the tumors that we diagnose
not only to assess for
the diagnostic hallmarks and tumors that
we suspect
have those hallmarks but also to exclude
those hallmarks
in some of the tumors uh
that uh that we might be uh that we
might be just assessing
histopathologically so
uh you know for instance if you have a
tumor that has an idh mutation well
you are basically um in the situation of
assessing whether that is an
oligodendroglioma or an idh
astrocytoma and you have to be able to
demonstrate
findings that would indicate one or the
other of those and in many cases that
that leads to you assessing for say a
1p19q co-deletion or the absence thereof
so as suggested by some of the examples
on the previous slide those hallmark
abnormalities include a wide range
different types of genomic aberrations
i've already mentioned this
uh and so the testing for all of those
changes is difficult to accomplish
with a single platform
and so different laboratories have uh
have gone about this a number of
different ways and
you can probably imagine uh that the
the different approaches to this problem
um have have been have varied widely
from location to location there's not
necessarily a cookbook provided to you
by the who
as to how you necessarily need to assess
for these abnormalities and
and and of course different pathologists
and different systems are going to be
a little bit different as to how exactly
they want to go about this as well so
i've just listed a few different um
uh mechanisms utilized by
neuropathologists to assess for some of
these abnormalities fortunately
i'm a pathologist right so i love
immunohistochemistry
so fortunately immunity chemistry uh has
played a big role
um in in assessing for some of these
diagnostic hallmarks uh there is a
really useful
for instance idh1 r132h
specific immunostain that's utilized by
labs all over the place
you can also assess for mutations and
fusions and such by sequencing and
pcr-based methods
you also see some copy number
abnormalities assessed by sequencing as
well
fish is still utilized by many
laboratories
to assess for certain of the copy number
hallmarks and some of the
the fusion abnormalities as well
methylation arrays i mentioned here um
primarily
uh this is something that is has been
implemented in
a few sites around the united states and
uh has been adopted in europe as well
particularly in germany as a
way of assisting with the diagnosis of
cns neoplasms
basically there is a mechanism to allow
you to
generate methylation array data and then
compare that to
a database methylation
fingerprinting system fundamentally
and compare how similar the tumor that
you're looking at is
to the databased um
tumors from the past uh and then uh
microarrays is what we have run here at
emory primarily and that some places
uh do uh racgh um
and uh and then snip arrays and
chromosomal mic arrays
um are utilized in a variety of
institutions as well so
um you you you end up using different
combinations of these based upon exactly
where you are what type of platforms
you're running so forth
um and uh and and there's not
necessarily a
uh an overarching um
uh mandate on behalf of any of the
of any of the who or the professional
organizations for exactly what you
should do
but just trying to give you an idea of
what's done
so for microarrays
we have run this now for uh
over six years here at emory and we've
tested
uh well over 1500 brain tumors um
uh at emory uh on our chromosomal
microarray system
uh and so we've also tested some other
some other uh uh tumors that hemato
hematological
malignancies are pretty commonly uh
tested in our laboratory
uh some some kidney neoplasms a fair
variety of other solid tumors but the
but the but the majority have been cns
tumors
so as we've been um working
on our clinical specimens generating
data to assist with clinical diagnosis
of tumors
we have basically watched the field grow
and change substantially the the amount
of knowledge that exists
for uh the interpretation of copy number
abnormalities and brain tumors
uh today is is substantially greater
than when we started
uh way back uh in 2014 so
um we continue to refine our approach
uh incorporating all these new data um
and uh and and it's really exciting
uh when we learn new things and we see
how other folks
have interpreted some of the findings
that we have have observed and
really uh really uh is is uh
um it's really a great era to practice
in from my perspective
so the interesting thing for us at emory
um has been that we actually have
been in the situation of using
microarray
really is the sole whole genome assay
that we run
on our our brain tumors in-house
so uh you know there's a variety of
reasons for this
for this situation but we basically have
not
to date implemented a large ngs panel
to cover a wide variety of genes
um implicated in in cnsd inflation we
have a small
pcr based panel that covers sort of the
the
absolutely necessary genes to to run
uh a competent diagnostic panel um for
cns neoplasia things like idh1 and idh2
the
the major the major uh uh genes that you
might want to know about brain tumors
um but we haven't had we haven't we
don't have a panel that covers a lot of
a lot of mutations that we don't we
don't also have don't have a
a fusion assay uh that uh
that that covers a wide variety of brain
tumor-specific
genes so we've really had to rely on the
microarray
um we do send for methylation profiling
um on a few cases but uh that's really
just a few
we run we run the microarrays on just
about every brain tumor we see
and we have had to basically work very
hard
to to push that data as far as we can
in order to get as much information as
we can and i
i kind of feel like sometimes i am when
i'm
writing reports for uh the microarray
workups that we do i feel like sometimes
i'm sort of leaving breadcrumbs
for my clinical colleagues and uh and of
course i'll call up
my you know the colleagues in pathology
who are signing out
some of the uh the histopathology
reports
and kind of you know you oftentimes i'll
be looking at the array data and
thinking about what could this
potentially represent a fusion a copy
number break at a certain area
or you know maybe you pick up an area
that looks very complex or may all even
chromothrypsis involving a certain
portion
of a chromosome and you start to think
well maybe
maybe there's a rearrangement in this
area that i just can't quite tell by the
array
but i can suggest potentially looking
um you know to to confirm uh a
rearrangement
using some sort of targeted uh testing
either fish or
sending for for um for fusion
testing it's it's it's been an
interesting experience and so
really i we rely on the array data in
conjunction with the histopathology i
mean it's chemistry and
and this smaller mutation panel to guide
us as to
you know what what maybe do we need to
send out for additional testing or
or you know suggest to the to uh
to the to the clinicians and our
colleagues about um
some additional abnormalities that might
be relevant based upon um
doing array testing say you know you
have an loh
involving uh one of the mismatch repair
genes and i've had situations where i'll
suggest
testing for mmr multi mismatch repair
ihc based upon an area
of elevation and by golly you know the
thing turns out to be
uh uh uh you know a potentially uh
mismatch repair deficient uh neoplasm um
so there's there's a variety of things
that you can find with array data
if you really um if you really really
pour over it
um and uh and and we still we still are
excited
um by uh by buying new things that we
can find utilizing
uh this this sort of a warhorse
technology
so uh recently in cns neoplasia
there's been some additional um uh
developments that have uh
basically uh uh been incorporated
into our diagnostic paradigm um
in sort of a what i would think of as a
wh o
plus mechanism so um
since the 2016 who there was a
clear agreement in the neuropathology
community that
uh the who only meets every few years
and uh we knew that based upon the pace
of the development and knowledge
our 2016 who was going to become
a little bit long in the tooth uh sooner
than
uh than than it might have in the past
and and we knew that our diagnostic
criteria needed to be able to change
a little bit more uh flexibly um
without without necessarily having to
wait for the next who to come out
in order for us to kind of keep up with
the with the state of knowledge
and so with that in mind there was a
group
form called the c impact now group which
is the consortium to inform
molecular and practical approaches to
cns tumor
taxonomy um and uh
and and and so it's a mouthful right
it's not the formal who so it's not
necessarily
a a formal who
publication um but it's comprised of
individuals who worked on the 2016 who
and who will be working on the upcoming
who that should be coming
relatively soon um and it this group
publishes periodic updates
to propose new classification schemes
and approaches and they
they they've been working now for about
three years and they're
they've published seven updates to date
to basically suggest
updates to the diagnostic paradigms
suggested in the 2016 who
um that can influence practice moving
forward
so with that in mind i uh put together
just a couple of case studies to
uh assist in understanding um
some of the see impact now material and
then some other
portions of newer literature um
basically just a way to highlight some
some of the ways that we've
uh that we've looked at genomic
data uh here at emory um and
and uh and used it to assist us in in
diagnosis
of some of the some of the the more
uh newly accepted tumor classifications
so got a couple of cases to go over and
we i'll i'll show you some pictures
it's going to be fine um we'll just go
over some h
e's quickly so our first case
is uh this is a
a man in his 60s it's an infiltrative
front of parietal mass
it's focally enhancing on on
mr imaging and uh so this is a
this is a uh an h e uh picture here
and it shows you basically hypercellular
brain tissue and if you
you're you have a fairly broad
differential diagnosis of
hypercellular brain tissue um but if you
look
fairly closely at these cells um
you'll notice that they are
fairly similar from one to the next
fairly similar and fairly similarly
odd looking so to a histopathologist
uh this is the picture of an
infiltrating glioma
these cells look glial and they are
spread
through the background brain in a way
that really
only glial cells or infiltrating gliomas
would do
so and when you're dealing with an
infiltrating glioma in a patient in this
age range you're pretty worried
um you're thinking about something that
could be
um aggressive um and so
so therefore your your senses are
tingling you're looking around for some
of the cardinal features
of a glioblastoma and of course the
first thing you want to be looking for
is mitotic activity
and and i've just highlighted here a
mitotic figure
that we found in this tumor but
we did not find the cardinal features
of glioblastoma from a histopathological
perspective there was no necrosis
no proliferative vasculature so we could
not make the diagnosis of gbm
based upon the um
the the biopsy material that was sent to
us
so what we did was we ran an array on
the material and
what we saw this is a whole genome view
of
the array in this case and
just to summarize first things first i'm
actually
showing you the fact that this is a
triploid tumor we
interpreted this array in the context of
a triploid
background um and you'll notice that
that
uh that the uh that the yellow line
there is sort of the
new normal that we have assigned to this
tumor
and in that context we interpreted
there being a whole chromosome gain of
seven
whole chromosome loss of 10 in this
tumor
and you can't really see it because it's
a little bit out of the frame but there
is an amplification
of each of the egfr locus on 7p
and then there's also a homozygous loss
of of 9p that includes the cdk into
a gene and so with this in mind
if we were to think about what
abnormalities we would
typically see with a classic
idh wild-type glioblastoma
well they would be many of the things
that i just mentioned you would look for
a whole chromosome k-7
you look for whole chromosome loss of 10
and you would look for an egfr
amplification those are things that we
commonly see in idh wild type
glioblastomas
so in summary basically we've got
an r tumor uh uh the
the one that we're attempting to
diagnose we see many of the
abnormalities that we often see in idh
wild type gpms but we don't have
the histopathologic findings to be able
to say that
so um the verdict here is that we're
dealing with something that's
troublesome we are
seriously worried about this tumor and
we
we really think that it's a glioblastoma
based upon the
uh the genomic data that we have
but um so
the the the then the question comes well
how how could this be
i mean there has to it has to be a gbm
look at look at the
all of the abnormalities but
how how could it be that it doesn't have
the histopathologic abnormalities well
it's a nasal needle biopsy sometimes the
surgeons miss the foci of necrosis they
miss the vascular proliferation
um and so uh you know you just can't
quite make it there because
the abnormalities just aren't present on
the slides and then the other thing is
well maybe the tumor hasn't quite yet
developed those
his diagnostic histopathologic features
remember this is just this
by imaging this was focally enhancing
and usually with something that has a
bunch of necrosis and vascular
proliferation you're going to see
ring enhancement that's the classic
imaging feature of a gpm
so in any event we're sitting there we
got a problem here we we have something
that we believe is a gbm
but we can't quite call it based upon
what we've got
on the slides so um this was a
fairly common issue in neuropathology
and uh the the uh see impact now
group got together and basically
wondered well are there is there a way
that are we do we feel confident enough
that there are certain molecular
findings
that would allow us to say this is a
glioblastoma
even without having some of the these
long-time
hallmark histopathologic features the
answer was yes
so they felt like um
uh there was there were certain
abnormalities that we could say okay if
you've got
if you're in an the cerebrum
of an adult and you have an infiltrating
astrocytic tumor um that's idh wild type
uh if you have certain abnormalities you
can basically say
it's a glioblastoma all right it's
this is important it it it it's a
diagnosis that
allows the entry of gbm into the
diagnostic line
and it allows patients to get on to
clinical trials perhaps because they
have glioblastoma
issued by the pathologist and it really
familiarizes patients in treating
physicians
with the expected behavior of the tumor
so
the concept here is of a diffuse
astrocytic glioma
idh wild type with molecular features of
glioblastoma who grade four
so you're getting you're getting the
sense here right this is another big
mouthful right
um and uh and and uh it's quite possible
that in the near future we will just
call these quote unquote molecular gbms
uh but for right now this is the this is
the diagnostic terminology that we're
using
um and this terminology was proposed
specifically
for this situation some a tumor that you
have genomic evidence that it is a
glioblastoma but you don't have the
histopathologic
findings to issue that specific
diagnosis
so um basically what were the
genomic abnormalities that that
that were proposed to satisfy the this
requirement
and uh basically it uh
it requires finding and infiltrating
glioma and the super tutorial brain of
an adult
with egfr amplification or
combined whole chromosome gain of 7 lost
a 10
or a tert promoter mutation so if you
were in that scenario
and you can find one of those three uh
abnormalities then you can use this
new diagnostic terminology
so in this case that's what we did we
called it diffuse astrocytic glioma idh
wild type with molecular features of
glioblastoma while grade 4
and i have to tell you when we first
issued this diagnosis this is
um this is not totally new it's been
around for
uh a little over a year i believe
and uh when we first utilized it our
clinical teams were thinking what are
you doing
you know this is really weird um and uh
they were somewhat alarmed by it uh but
of course we've been using
array data in our diagnostics for a
while so
we were able to kind of assuage them and
uh uh and and really since we started
utilizing this diagnosis we
used it a fair a number of times about
it once a month at least
we utilize it um and uh and now we're in
the situation where we really
very rarely utilize the diagnosis of
anaplastic
astrocytoma idh wild type because
frankly most tumors that previously fell
into that category
show the molecular hallmarks of a
glioblastoma
so this is a good another reminder that
the generation of genomic data
for cases like this is is really
critical
so case two um we're
we're dealing with a a younger gentleman
um and he has a mass in his temporal
brain
very densely cellular and you can see
even from
this low power image there are some big
cells in here that look really weird
and so on higher power indeed
this thing is jam-packed with bad cells
um and uh they are not showing
uh exactly uh all of the features of a
typical glioblastoma they don't have a
ton
of fibrillarity in the background they
are showing
clearly malignant features you can see
scattered around the slide those uh
those
very dark structures uh some of them
maybe look like little clusters of
chromosomes well those are mitotic
figures
um so there's quite a few of them here
in this image you can
uh see see one in the bottom left-hand
corner that looks a little bit like a
stick figure that's an atypical mitotic
figure
so this is another malignancy
something we're again quite worried
about
um and uh we were able to confirm that
it did
have a expression of glial markers
so it's a high-grade glioma
and we did some additional workup that
suggested that it might have an atrx
mutation we did
an immunostain for atrx and it shows you
that
there are some strong there's some
strong immune reactivity in some of the
cells the smaller cells in the
background
but our big cells are either not
showing very much reactivity at all
they're very light brown
or they're showing no immunoreactivity
they're blue
so maybe this is an indicator of an atrx
mutation
uh and then our p53 immunostain was very
strongly positive
and uh quite suggestive of a tp53
mutation
so uh usually in a younger person who
has a
a malignant glioma that has an atrx
mutation
and uh or a suggestion of an atrx
mutation and a t-53 mutation
first thing you think about is well
could it be an idh mutant tumor
and this tumor ended up not having an
idh mutation
um so then we're sitting there kind of
scratching our heads wondering what
could be going on
um and we look at our array data
and uh it shows and
a whole chromosome gain of 7 but no loss
of
of chromosome 10 um and
uh no whole chromosome loss of 10 and so
uh
you know didn't exactly fit with our the
idh
wild gbms that we just looked at
a moment ago it does have
a an amplification of 4p
that includes the pdgfra gene and then
it also has a loss of 4q
and so taking all this together we've
got a lot to think about
so this is clearly a high grade neoplasm
and a younger person we have to think
about an embryonal tumor but we're
thinking this is probably a glioma based
upon some of our
some of our findings um it
it it's idh wild type in the sense that
it doesn't have an idh mutation
right but it's not exactly the same as
the idh wild type gbms that we looked at
just previously the classic example and
the
and our uh diffuse astrocytic glioma
molecular gpm
right so um doesn't have the
some of those cardinal hallmarks that we
just talked about
however the ihc findings that
probable tp53 mutation the probable atrx
mutation and the copy number data and
particularly the
loss of 4q and the amplification of pdg
fra
raises another possibility in this tumor
and there are a variety of different
histone mutant tumors
um that have been defined uh
including uh pretty much most famously
the
2016 who defined um the
diffuse midline glioma that is
characterized by a k-27m
mutation of the h3 uh
h3 f3a gene or a variety of other
genes um histone genes and so
uh there's some of these histone
genes are seen along the midline in
children
and most commonly in adults
but we're not in the midline here so why
am i bringing this up this is
but the reason is these are not the only
cns tumors that have been associated
with
histone mutations and there are a group
of tumors called the
h3 uh g34 mutant tumors
um that in contrast to the k-27 in
mutant tumors
uh these the g-34 mutants are usually
seen
in the cerebral hemispheres and they can
show an embryonal-like histology very
densely packed tumor cells kind of
similar to what we saw
in this case they may display atrx
mutations or loss of atrx expression
they may show tp3 mutations they can
have pdgfra amplifications
and they may show a loss of 3q and or 3
3q or 4q
and so with that in mind we sent this
tumor for additional sequencing
and um the the end
diagnosis was this is an idh wild type
glioblastoma
uh who grade four however it
is a specific type uh a g34
mutant idh wild type gpm
okay so this is fundamentally a
different tumor type
than the quote-unquote idh wild-type
gbms
that we were speaking about in the first
case um
and so here the combination of
histologic and immunohis-chemical and
genomic data
sort of pointed us in the direction of
necessary
additional sequencing um
and uh and allowed us to be able to make
the most
accurate diagnosis for this patient um
and this this particular histone mutant
class the g34
mutant tumors mentioned in 2016 who but
really since that time has been uh
better established in the literature so
we were we together have reviewed the
use of copy number data in the modern
assessment of cns neoplasia
and we've summarized the importance of
some of the newer diagnostic paradigms
including
at least one of those derived from the c
c impact now project there are quite a
few others i
and i encourage you to read those papers
if you have not
already and
in summary genomic data including copy
number data
insta indispensable part of the modern
diagnosis and workup of cns neoplasia
um the exact mechanisms and the
platforms that would be utilized
is institution and somewhat situation
dependent
uh however broad spectrum mechanisms are
extremely useful in detecting unique and
recently described
entities and i
really feel like genomic information is
critical particularly broad spectrum
genomic information is critical
to my practice so
uh some acknowledgements i i really
couldn't do
uh this type of of work without
the tutelage and assistance of
the teams in molecular pathology and
oncology cytogenetics here
at emory uh i of course rely on my
colleagues in neuropathology
to assist me as well and of course
have a lot of support from my clinical
colleagues and neurosurgery
neuro-oncology
radiation oncology and uh and some
and some great informatics support from
our pathology it staff
so with that i will uh say thank you
very much
um and uh we'll take some questions and
if uh at the end of the lecture i have
not had a
chance to um to cover what you uh what
you what you're interested in please
feel free to email me thank you